Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
Sobriété : entre croissance
et décroissance.
Sobriété et croissance,
d'abord.
Un oxymore,
quasiment une contradiction,
à l'aune du "en même temps",
en vue de réduire
les consommations individuelles,
tout en déployant
un agenda national
de production.
Sobriété et décroissance,
un défi social,
en même temps
qu'un pari idéologique et lyrique,
la sobre ivresse de la vie,
selon Ivan Illich,
l'apôtre inspiré
de la décroissance.
Si croissance et décroissance
s'opposent,
terme à terme,
en vue de reconfigurer
l'Etat-providence,
l'économie de marché,
les modes de vie, la démographie,
le progrès et la science,
il en est différemment
avec la sobriété,
évoquée sans discernement.
Alors, s'agit-il
d'un simple mot-valise,
d'une espèce
de fourre-tout conceptuel
à polarité positive,
quand il s'agit d'éviter
tous les gaspillages à même
de porter atteinte au climat,
à la biodiversité,
à la finitude
de certaines ressources,
à l'obésité consumériste
des individus ?
Ou s'agit-il d'un trompe-l'oeil
politique,
quand il est question
d'arbitrer les pénuries
par l'exhortation
à de petits gestes individuels
et de repousser
aux calendes grecques
la persistance
des inégalités sociales
chez nous,
comme, plus gravement,
dans les pays du Sud,
en quête de développement
et de rattrapage
pour mieux s'inscrire
dans la mondialisation ?
Vous l'avez compris.
Nous allons traiter d'un sujet
qui est autant politique
que polémique,
autant socio-économique
qu'axiologique,
c'est-à-dire dépendant
des valeurs,
et notamment des valeurs
de liberté, de démocratie,
de solidarité.
Pour en parler,
je signale que
nous sommes en visioconférence
avec M. Boris Ravignon,
président de l'ADEME
et maire
de Charleville-Mézières.
Bonjour, M. Ravignon.
*-Bonjour, M. Malet.
Bonjour à tous.
-Hélène Peskine,
vous êtes architecte
et urbaniste générale de l'Etat
et secrétaire permanente du PUCA.
Bonjour,
M. Olivier Lluansi.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes spécialiste
de l'industrie
à PwC.
Bonjour,
Louis Gallois.
Vous êtes coprésident
de la Fabrique de l'industrie,
ancien président d'Airbus
et de la SNCF.
Bonjour,
Mme Barbara Pompili.
Vous êtes députée de la Somme.
Vous êtes ancienne ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Vous avez vu la citation
de M. Castoriadis.
C'est cet imaginaire
capitaliste
qui va dans le sens
de la croissance
et du développement.
Est-ce que vous pensez possible,
aujourd'hui,
une reconversion écologique
de notre économie,
qui viendrait enserrer
la croissance
dans des contraintes
environnementales
et sociales ?
Vous commencez, M. Ravignon ?
-Alors, volontiers,
volontiers.
Je crois que ce sujet
que vous évoquez,
c'est un sujet
qui est au coeur
des travaux de prospective
de l'ADEME,
que je préside maintenant
depuis quelques semaines.
J'ai pris connaissance
de manière assez approfondie
des travaux que nous publions,
que publie l'agence,
notamment celui qui s'appelle
Transition(s) 2050,
où on essaie d'imaginer
les différents scénarios
qui vont nous permettre d'atteindre
la décarbonation de l'économie
et de notre société.
La neutralité carbone
à l'horizon 2050,
c'est l'une des conditions
du respect des engagements
de l'accord de Paris.
Cet... Ce...
Cet objectif, on a plusieurs moyens
de l'atteindre.
C'est la grande valeur ajoutée
des travaux de l'ADEME
d'avoir imaginé
plusieurs scénarios,
l'un extrêmement sobre,
où on va jusqu'à diviser par deux
la consommation d'énergie,
et puis, à l'opposé,
le scénario 4
qui, lui, va...
Il laisse dériver
la consommation d'énergie.
Et puis, des scénarios où il y a
une composante de sobriété variable.
Eh bien,
ce qu'on constate
dans ces modèles
- et l'ADEME a tenu à modéliser
un certain nombre
de paramètres macro-économiques
sur la croissance, l'emploi,
la balance commerciale -
c'est que nous pouvons effectivement
atteindre cette neutralité carbone
et qu'aucun des scénarios
que nous avons retenus
ne prévoit une récession,
par rapport au niveau d'activité
d'aujourd'hui.
-Vous êtes en train
de nous dire que
les scénarios ne prévoient pas
une récession,
c'est-à-dire une chute
de la croissance.
-Effectivement.
-On peut faire de la sobriété,
tout en ayant de la croissance ?
C'est ce que vous dites.
-C'est ce que les modèles,
effectivement, produisent.
Alors, ces modèles...
Ce modèle,
il est central, naturellement,
dans les anticipations.
Il a fait l'objet
d'une analyse assez approfondie
par M. Pisani-Ferry,
il y a encore quelques mois.
On a une assez grande confiance
dans le fait que,
aujourd'hui,
remplacer les énergies fossiles
par des énergies renouvelables,
diminuer
- c'est prévu
sur ces trajectoires -
la consommation d'un certain nombre
de biens manufacturés,
d'importations,
pour les remplacer
par des consommations plus locales,
par une consommation de services
davantage produits localement,
avoir des trajectoires
dans lesquelles
on investit énormément
dans une meilleure efficacité
énergétique de nos bâtiments,
au niveau des prix de l'énergie
que nous connaissons,
ça a un véritable
rendement économique.
Non seulement, on rembourse
le capital qu'on emprunte,
quand on fait
des travaux d'isolation sur le bâti,
mais on dégage aussi
du revenu supplémentaire.
On a, je crois,
les éléments, effectivement,
non seulement d'un modèle
de transition écologique,
où on gagne en sobriété,
en efficacité énergétique,
où on atteint
nos objectifs écologiques,
mais où on ne dégrade pas
la situation macro-économique.
Au contraire,
on continue à avoir
une progression de la richesse.
-On vous a entendu,
M. Ravignon.
Mme Pompili,
vous avez été ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Alors, ça change.
Des fois,
c'est Transition énergétique.
En tout cas,
vous avez été
la tête pensante
de l'écologie,
dans un gouvernement de la majorité,
avec M. Macron
comme président.
Pour vous, c'est possible
d'enserrer la croissance
dans des contraintes
écologiques ?
-Je suis interpellée
par la manière
dont vous posez la question.
Vous dites
"enserrer", "contraintes".
Déjà, vous mettez quelque part
un jugement de valeur...
-Non, je n'en porte aucun.
Rassurez-vous.
-Sur la transition écologique.
La transition écologique,
ça nécessite effectivement
de se projeter
et d'essayer d'apporter,
face à un état des lieux du monde
dans lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui,
un certain nombre de solutions.
M. Ravignon a expliqué
très clairement
que les outils existent.
C'est pas une question d'outils.
On les a,
mais je crois profondément,
pour avoir exercé des fonctions
qui m'ont permis
de toucher du doigt le problème,
qu'on ne peut mettre en place
tous ces outils
que si on réussit
à raconter un récit
de ce qu'on veut construire.
Quand vous dites
"contraintes" et "enserrer",
vous présentez
la transition écologique
comme, quelque part,
l'adaptation à quelque chose
qui nous tombe dessus
et qui est négatif.
-On va entrer dans le débat,
mais vous verrez qu'il faudra
consommer moins d'énergie,
consommer moins d'eau, etc.,
donc ce sont des contraintes.
-Oui,
mais la vie en société est une vie
qui est composée de contraintes.
Nous avons des lois,
des règles.
Quand il s'agit
d'écologie,
ce sont des contraintes.
C'est difficile.
Or, ce sont des règles de vie
en commun.
Ce que je trouve très intéressant
dans ce que nous vivons,
c'est que nous sommes obligés
- ça, c'est vrai -
de réinterroger le monde
dans lequel nous vivons
et les valeurs
que nous avons portées
pendant des années.
Est-ce que le monde
dans lequel nous vivons
est un monde souhaitable
et un monde heureux ?
Je trouve que c'est passionnant.
On ne peut entraîner tout le monde
dans des changements
de mode de vie...
-Mais la question...
-...que si on explique
vers où on veut aller.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est ce qui manque.
On va trop vite vers l'outil,
sans expliquer
qu'on peut construire un monde
dans lequel on peut
être mieux qu'aujourd'hui.
C'est pas parce qu'on achète
deux fois moins
de pulls
qu'on sera moins bien chauffé
ou qu'on sera moins heureux.
C'est pas parce qu'on a
une voiture qui sera moins grosse,
avec un autre moteur,
ou parce qu'on prendra
d'autres types de transport
qu'on sera moins heureux.
-Là, vous explicitez
votre vision écologiste
ou écologique.
La question
que je vous pose
est plus simple que ça
et sans jugement de valeur.
C'est de savoir si,
en respectant toutes ces...
Que vous appeliez ça
des normes, des contraintes,
ou que vous appeliez ça
simplement,
pour vous, une nécessité,
est-ce qu'on arrivera
à maintenir la croissance du pays ?
Voilà. C'est tout.
C'est pas plus que ça.
-Oui, mais est-ce qu'on arrivera
à maintenir la croissance du pays,
la croissance étant donc
l'alpha et l'oméga
de toute politique publique ?
-J'ai pas dit ça.
Je vous pose
la question.
-Je vous dis simplement
- c'est des grands exemples
qu'on sort depuis longtemps -
qu'une guerre booste très fort
le taux de croissance d'un pays.
Est-ce que c'est forcément cela
qu'on veut obtenir ?
Moi, je n'ai jamais été
de ces gens
qui poussaient
pour la décroissance totale.
Je pense qu'on peut avoir
un développement économique
équilibré
d'un pays et du monde...
-On va entrer dans le détail.
-...que la sobriété peut
paradoxalement entraîner
une hausse du PIB,
puisque beaucoup d'emplois
vont être créés
dans la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments.
On peut créer de nouvelles
filières économiques.
La réponse à votre question
est oui,
mais il me semble que...
Il faut développer,
car c'est simpliste.
-On va détailler.
Louis Gallois,
par rapport
à la question posée,
qu'est-ce que vous dites,
vous ?
-Moi, je crois
que la décroissance
est un véritable risque,
sous deux aspects :
la remise en cause
de l'Etat-providence,
puisqu'on n'aurait plus
les ressources pour le financer,
ou il faudrait être
extrêmement coercitif
sur la réduction
des inégalités,
avec un gâteau qui se rétrécit,
et, deuxièmement,
on a besoin de croissance
pour financer
les énormes investissements
que va susciter
la transition énergétique
en particulier.
La transition écologique en général,
mais surtout
la transition énergétique.
La question se pose.
Peut-on avoir une croissance verte ?
Il y a un débat.
-Et votre position ?
-Moi, ma position,
c'est que oui,
mais il y a quatre conditions.
La première :
il faut un effort
de recherche considérable,
car un certain nombre de solutions
seront technologiques
et supposent
de franchir des étapes.
Le stockage
de l'énergie.
On n'en est pas encore là,
par exemple.
Toutes les...
Les plastiques biodégradables.
Tous ces éléments
- je pourrais en citer une dizaine -
supposent
un effort de recherche considérable.
Second élément : il faut que
l'industrie modifie ses process
pour les décarboner.
Ca va coûter énormément d'argent
et ça n'a pas de rentabilité
pour les industriels
qui vont le faire,
donc il faut trouver
comment justifier
ces investissements,
du point de vue
de ces industriels qui,
faisant ces investissements,
ne pourront pas
en faire d'autres.
Troisième condition :
qu'on soit présents
sur les nouveaux marchés,
les nouvelles opportunités
qui se présentent
grâce à la croissance verte.
Vous avez cité
les matériaux,
les matériaux isolants.
Je peux vous citer
la viande végétale.
On peut citer, évidemment,
tout ce qui concerne
la production industrielle
d'énergie.
Je reviendrai sur ce point.
Les voitures,
les batteries, etc.
Sur ces marchés,
il faut se positionner.
C'est pas du tout évident.
-C'est pas évident,
mais vous croyez
à une croissance verte.
-On va les consommer,
ces produits.
Les fabriquer en France
n'est pas du tout évident.
On l'a vu
pour les panneaux solaires.
On n'en fabrique pas un en France.
On importe 100 %
des panneaux
et on n'est pas loin
de le faire
sur les éoliennes.
Quatrième condition,
pour tout cela :
il faut une énergie décarbonée.
Il faut une production électrique
qui devra être
nettement en progression,
puisque l'électricité,
qui représente à peu près
25 % du mix énergétique,
actuellement,
va représenter,
en 2050, 55 %
du mix énergétique.
Même si on consomme moins d'énergie,
on va consommer plus d'électricité.
Il faut produire cette électricité.
Je pense que c'est un point
tout à fait clé.
-Vous êtes tous d'accord
pour considérer
que la chose est possible,
mais dès lors que...
-Pas n'importe comment.
-...l'aménagement
puisse se faire.
Essayons d'aller un peu plus loin,
là-dessus.
Mme Peskine, on sort d'une crise
sanitaire.
Nous sommes
confrontés à la guerre
en Ukraine.
Les conséquences économiques
sont devant nous.
Rareté,
on l'a vu,
de certaines sources énergétiques.
Les prix
ont flambé.
Ne parlons pas de l'électricité.
S'est imposée cette notion
de sobriété énergétique,
aujourd'hui. Pourquoi pas ?
De toute manière,
les gens sont obligés de l'accepter.
Les résultats sont là,
puisque les citoyens
se sont montrés citoyens.
Mais, alors, la question...
-Non.
L'industrie a moins consommé.
-Oui, l'industrie,
mais aussi les particuliers,
Louis.
-Pas beaucoup, malheureusement.
-Disons que... Voilà.
La question
que je veux vous poser
concerne
tous ces gestes individuels,
que l'on demande aux personnes,
de sobriété.
C'est une chose,
mais en même temps,
la machine économique
et industrielle
s'emploie à tourner
à plein régime.
Il y a deux choses.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas, ici,
une contradiction dans les termes
et même dans les intentions ?
-Je voudrais dire trois choses
sur ce point.
D'abord, je pense que, finalement,
c'est plutôt salutaire
qu'on ait expérimenté tous,
collectivement,
dans le monde entier,
une sobriété obligatoire,
une contrainte très forte
sur l'approvisionnement
pendant la crise sanitaire,
et puis,
sur certains approvisionnements,
en céréales, en énergie,
depuis la crise en Ukraine.
Finalement, ce signal prix,
qui est le signal le plus efficace
pour apprendre à être plus sobre
et à reconnaître
de quoi on a besoin
pour fonctionner,
c'est un apprentissage accéléré,
à mon avis,
qui est bon pour la société.
On se rend bien mieux compte
de quoi on dépend.
On dépend individuellement
de beaucoup de choses.
Les collectivités locales
et les territoires
dépendent de ressources
nombreuses et variées,
avec des origines diverses.
L'Etat, la nation,
les entreprises...
Chacun dépend
d'un certain nombre
de ressources.
On ne mesurait pas,
avant ces crises,
à quel point
elles étaient distanciées.
-Les gens ne sont pas
plus heureux
de payer plus cher
leur électricité.
-Non, mais c'est une expérience
assez forte
pour prendre conscience d'enjeux
qu'on avait,
dans le contexte politique,
déjà évoqués,
mais qui n'étaient pas
fortement intégrés par les gens,
individuellement
et collectivement.
C'est vrai autant
pour les collectivités locales
que pour les entreprises
et que pour les individus.
Première chose.
La deuxième chose,
c'est qu'on a tendance
à réduire la notion de sobriété
ou l'ambition de sobriété
à la sobriété énergétique.
Or, on a expérimenté,
l'été dernier,
d'autres pénuries
que celle de l'énergie,
avec des problèmes de sécheresse
extrêmement importants,
l'été dernier.
Barbara Pompili,
qui s'occupe
de la gouvernance de l'eau,
pourra en parler.
On va devoir apprendre
à gérer d'autres types
de pénurie
et d'autres formules de sobriété,
sur l'eau,
sur les matières premières.
Je m'intéresse
à la construction.
On va manquer de sable
pour le béton.
On voit bien que cette difficulté
à s'approvisionner,
devant nous,
est de plus en plus forte.
Il faudra mettre en place
des régulations
de l'approvisionnement.
Le troisième point,
c'est qu'on ne doit pas
non plus réduire
cette idée de contraintes
sur les petits gestes
aux individus.
En réalité - et je le disais
pour les collectivités locales -
cette politique de sobriété
s'applique à tout décideur,
individuel ou collectif,
notamment
aux décideurs territoriaux,
aux entreprises qui,
on l'a vu pendant l'automne,
ont transformé leurs process,
voire fermé un certain nombre
de chaînes de production,
face au prix de l'énergie.
Elles aussi se posent
la question
de leurs process.
Cette notion
de sobriété n'est pas
à rapporter qu'aux individus
et aux petits gestes.
C'est bien une question
de transformation de la manière
dont la société
fait face
à son modèle économique.
-M. Olivier Lluansi,
je reste sur ma question.
Est-ce que vous ne voyez pas
une contradiction
entre ces gestes individuels
qui sont demandés
aux individus
et, en même temps,
la nécessité
de développer
l'outil économique
de production français ?
On insiste beaucoup
pour qu'il y ait
une réindustrialisation.
Parler de tout ça
en demandant des gestes de sobriété
à des individus...
Est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose à harmoniser
entre les deux ?
-C'est pas là que
je verrais la contradiction.
Est-ce qu'il y a un manque
de cohérence global
et de direction ? Oui.
Je reprends
ce que disait Mme Pompili.
Il faut qu'on ait un projet
sur lequel on se raccroche.
On a eu un projet de société
qui était
autour de l'équipement,
de la consommation,
qui a dérivé
à la consommation de masse.
Face à la demande, on a fait
un outil productif de masse,
avec toutes les prévarications
qu'il a eues sur l'environnement.
On a atteint des limites.
Ce modèle est dépassé.
On est en train de basculer
vers un autre projet
de société
qui n'est pas encore
pleinement défini.
C'est la 1re brique sur laquelle
on doit travailler collectivement.
On a plusieurs défis,
on parle de la sobriété,
ou pourrait aussi parler
de souveraineté,
il y a entre les deux
des injonctions contradictoires,
et donc, il va falloir que,
collectivement,
nous commencions à donner
une direction un peu ferme,
qui nous permette en tous les cas
de définir quel outil
productif on veut.
Un outil productif de souveraineté,
par exemple, va demander
d'ouvrir des mines en France.
Est-ce qu'on y est prêts
alors qu'on voudrait
préserver l'espace naturel ?
Entre les deux,
comment on choisit ?
Mais on n'a pas d'instance...
-Enfin,
ouvrir une mine naturelle,
c'est pas...
dévisager le paysage français,
-Oh, bah,
demandez à ceux qui vivent à côté,
regardez les difficultés
qu'il peut y avoir.
Je pense qu'il va falloir
réexploiter nos richesses
de sous-sol,
donc je pense
que c'est la direction,
mais demandez
à ceux qui vivent
à côté de ces sites.
Et on doit avoir cette obligation
d'écouter les territoires,
les citoyens qui y vivent,
pour leur qualité de vie.
Donc le premier point,
c'est quel est
notre projet collectif,
vers quoi on se projette,
et ça,
ça tourne autour de la sobriété,
de la circularité,
un bout de souveraineté aussi,
mais on a pas tout à fait défini.
A partir du moment où on aura ça,
il sera relativement facile
de définir quel est l'outil
productif qui va avec,
et qui sera certainement
beaucoup plus sobre.
Le mot-clef qui devrait émerger,
c'est celui de circularité.
Enfin voilà,
si je devais donner un pari,
c'est celui de circularité.
-Et que mettez-vous
dans cette circularité ?
-L'entièreté, notamment,
des matières premières
et le fait d'être capables
de reprendre un produit,
le recyclage matière étant
quasiment l'ultime solution,
mais la réparabilité,
la récupération des pièces,
la démontabilité seront clefs
dans tous les objets du quotidien
qu'on va avoir demain.
Donc l'industrie, notamment
tout ce qui produit nos objets,
cette chaise,
des livres, nos stylos,
nos smartphones,
est en face d'un défi
dont on ne connaît pas la direction
mais qu'on sent bien,
qui est celle de réinventer
tous les produits
et là, on n'a pas encore
tout à fait
les solutions.
On ne sait pas encore
faire la circularité,
c'est compliqué,
des produits autour de nous,
mais c'est un défi fantastique.
Est-ce qu'il va être
créateur d'activité ou pas ?
Il faut réfléchir
à ce qui s'est passé sur la voiture.
D'une motorisation thermique,
on est passé à la décision
d'une motorisation électrique.
C'est une décision politique
dans le sens symbolique,
on a dit : 2035, terminé.
Quand on regarde les études,
il faut du discernement.
Il y a des cas où l'usage
de la voiture électrique n'est pas
le meilleur pour l'environnement.
D'autres si.
Donc la première leçon,
c'est que, dans les décisions,
il faudra du discernement
et pas que du symbole.
Ca, on a du mal à le faire
collectivement.
Le deuxième élément,
c'est que, quand on a lancé
cette transition rapide,
on s'est pas réellement occupés
de toute la filière :
100 000 emplois en France concernés.
S'est-on occupés
de leur transformation ?
Veut-on un modèle de société
où le marché fait cette adaptation
ou bien la puissance publique ?
Donc on a aujourd'hui,
sans répondre à votre question
sur la...
on a un véritable enjeu,
quel est notre projet,
quelle est la façon dont on va faire
les produits servant ce projet
et comment on organise
la transition ?
-On vous a entendu là-dessus.
Alors, madame Pompili,
sur cette dualité
entre l'individu
d'un côté
et la collectivité de l'autre,
vous qui êtes une politique,
est-ce qu'il y a pas
un travail pédagogique à faire
pour que les gens
comprennent que les efforts
qu'on leur demande,
euh... doivent être,
si je puis dire,
à la mesure
de ce que le pouvoir
politique peut faire
pour transformer globalement
tout le processus ?
-C'est un point central,
et je rejoins ce que vous disiez,
on a besoin d'un récit pour dire
à tout le monde
vers où on veut aller,
parce que si on n'a pas
ce récit-là,
vous allez avoir des réactions,
qu'on voit
aujourd'hui, des réactions de peur,
d'inquiétude
face à l'avenir,
où on ne voit que les contraintes
justement et où on n'arrive
pas à se projeter.
Ca entraîne des manifestations,
la plus emblématique
étant celle des gilets jaunes,
qui a bien montré
qu'une partie de la population,
aujourd'hui,
a le sentiment que le monde
avance sans elle
et on peut retranscrire ça
au niveau mondial,
on a un certain nombre de pays
qui ont l'impression
que le monde avant sans eux et qui,
du coup, ne sont pas partie prenante
de cette transition.
On ne réussira pas à faire
ce qu'on veut faire
quand bien même on trouverait
tous les outils
si on n'a pas cette adhésion
au futur qu'on veut
construire.
Et se rajoute à cela la complexité
que nous sommes dans un monde ouvert
et qu'on ne peut plus
réfléchir aux solutions
uniquement au niveau national
ou même au niveau
régional,
on a besoin d'une visibilité
et d'avoir un travail
que l'on fait au niveau
continental.
-Mais alors,
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que le gouvernement
fait ce que vous dites ?
-Je pense que...
-Le gouvernement actuel.
Ou est-ce qu'il y a
une insuffisance de pédagogie ?
Je sais que c'est difficile
de critiquer ses successeurs,
mais bon...
-Et puis, en plus,
c'est un travail
de long terme.
Je pense qu'il y a une chose
"de très" positive qui a été mise
en place par le gouvernement,
c'est le fait de décider
d'avoir un organisme accolé
à la Première ministre qui est
en charge de la planification.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça oblige,
quelque part,
tout le monde à prendre,
je vais employer le terme
de charge mentale,
à prendre la charge mentale
de la transition écologique
qui, avant,
était quand même laissée
au soin du ministre
en charge de l'environnement.
Moi, je l'ai vécu,
même si y a beaucoup d'efforts
qui avaient été faits...
-Donc ça vous gêne pas
que le ministre en charge
ne soit pas un écologiste,
par exemple,
n'appartienne pas
à un parti écologiste ?
-Non, à partir du moment
où tout le monde prend...
prend en compte cette...
cette... ce point.
Moi, ce qui me gêne un petit peu,
c'est qu'on a aussi
des gens qui ont une culture...
qui ont pas vraiment
une culture écologiste et qui ont
simplement une conscience
qu'on a un objet...
qui est :
des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
trop importantes
et qu'il faut réduire,
et donc on a des gens
qui réfléchissent à des outils
pour réduire ces émissions.
Mais ça, c'est très important,
mais c'est insuffisant à mon sens
si on veut avoir un récit collectif
encore une fois qui est
la base de tout le travail.
-On a pu vous entendre.
Hélène Peskine ?
-Je voulais rebondir
sur ce que disait
Olivier Lluansi :
la nécessité de relocaliser
l'industrie qui pourrait
être en contradiction
avec cette logique de sobriété
prônée par le pouvoir en place
mais, en fait, je crois
qu'il faut arrêter de penser
que sobriété et croissance
sont divergentes.
Je pense que, aujourd'hui,
on a fait la preuve
que des politiques de sobriété,
d'économie de matières
et d'énergie sont créatrices
d'emplois, d'abord,
on l'a dit sur la rénovation
des bâtiments par exemple,
c'est une politique publique
créatrice d'emplois
dans le bâtiment,
on le voit, justement,
sur la relocalisation de mines,
on vient d'ouvrir une mine
de lithium en Auvergne
dans un ancien bassin minier.
Les gens sont satisfaits,
en tout cas le territoire
accueille plutôt favorablement
cette ouverture.
-C'est pas fini.
-C'est le début !
-Mais plutôt favorablement
dans le sens où ça redonne
une activité économique
à un bassin d'emplois
qui était en déprise.
Donc sous réserve de comprendre
dans quel monde on se situe
et pourquoi la relocalisation
est bénéfique à l'environnement,
au sens où on diminue
les distances parcourues
par les matières premières,
on crée du positif
avec un récit reçu
négativement.
Il y a besoin d'exemples concrets
pour expliquer comment on crée
de la richesse et une forme
de prospérité à partir
de politiques visant à réduire
nos dépendances,
ces kilomètres parcourus,
donc du carbone émis
dans l'atmosphère,
voilà, et à améliorer
notre capacité à être suffisants
dans un certain nombre
de domaines économiques.
-Monsieur Boris Ravignon,
vous vouliez intervenir là-dessus,
mais je voudrais également
que vous interveniez sur le point
que je vous suggère.
Est-ce que, à votre avis,
sans signal prix,
c'est-à-dire une vraie
taxation du carbone,
est-ce qu'on n'est pas réduits
à faire du bricolage écologique ?
*-Alors, je me permettrai...
Je vous réponds juste
dans la foulée.
Je voulais simplement réagir
au débat pour dire que,
on le voit bien,
c'est d'ailleurs un peu
aussi le thème de votre...
de notre...
émission d'aujourd'hui, c'est,
il y a une forme
d'éco-anxiété aujourd'hui,
une inquiétude sur à la fois
l'évolution écologique
de notre planète,
la dégradation
et le changement climatique,
et tout ce qu'elle implique,
et puis l'inquiétude sur les voies,
les trajectoires,
les moyens par lesquels passer
pour atteindre les objectifs,
pour agir, finalement,
et aller vers, vers, vers cette...
vers une amélioration
de la situation.
Mais donc, je crois quand même,
on peut toujours effectivement
trouver le verre à moitié vide,
mais qu'un certain nombre d'outils
commencent à être en place,
que sur le fait, par exemple,
de... de programmer,
de planifier les évolutions,
et on parle pas
de petites évolutions.
Je vais prendre juste un exemple.
On sait qu'on doit,
pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050,
faire que 90 % des logements,
des 30 millions de logements
que nous avons,
c'est-à-dire
27 millions de logements,
rien que ça,
se trouvent en 2050
avec des niveaux de consommation
qui sont ceux du BBC.
C'est un niveau
extrêmement exigeant,
on divise par trois la consommation
moyenne des logements
par mètre carré.
Donc pour faire ce travail-là,
il faut qu'on passe de 41 000
rénovations BBC qu'on a "fait"
sur la période récente à 700 000.
Alors, accessoirement,
ça va créer
pas mal d'emplois, ça va...
mais effectivement,
ça requiert des investissements.
Eh bien, aujourd'hui,
on commence à avoir, sur les...
vraiment, dans France 2030,
dans les politiques conduites,
des moyens pour accompagner
ces investissements,
ces investissements qui sont,
à la différence de ceux
dont parlait Louis Gallois
tout à l'heure pour une partie
de ceux des industriels, rentables.
C'est des investissements qui,
quand ils vont être faits,
au bout du compte,
vont dégager du revenu,
pour les locataires,
une fois remboursé leur prêt,
qui vont se retrouver
dans un logement mieux isolé.
Et puis, on commence à mettre
en place aussi les moyens
destinés à la décarbonation
de l'industrie,
ça a été rappelé, c'est crucial,
la moitié de France 2030,
des 54 milliards de France 2030,
est consacrée à la décarbonation
de notre économie,
donc les outils sont là.
Mais c'est vrai,
et je rejoins ce qui a été dit
par Hélène Peskine
et Barbara Pompili,
on a besoin que
les représentations évoluent.
Si le fait de...
Parce que le prix du carburant,
et c'est un peu une réponse
aussi à ce que,
à la question que vous posiez
sur les prix de l'énergie,
si le prix du carburant
vous incite à prendre votre vélo
plutôt que votre voiture,
vous le vivez comme,
finalement, une déchéance totale,
vous n'êtes plus capable
de transporter votre SUV
de 1,5 tonne sur 300 ou 400 mètres
pour aller chercher
la baguette de pain
et vous devez prendre votre vélo,
si vous le vivez comme ça,
effectivement,
le récit qu'on a de ce moment-là,
c'est une contrainte terrible
qui m'oblige à faire quelque chose
d'extrêmement désagréable.
Si, en réalité,
vous vous inscrivez
dans le développement du...
finalement, de l'utilisation
du vélo au quotidien,
qui est à la fois,
a des vertus écologiques,
économiques,
car ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
que de transporter des tonnes
de métal pour des petites distances
qu'on peut faire plus légèrement,
et meilleur à votre santé,
vous n'avez pas exactement la même
vision de cette même expérience
et donc ça...
-Mais monsieur Ravignon,
il faut faire entrer
des sous dans la caisse.
Est-ce que,
sans une taxation du carbone,
qui soit une véritable taxation,
on peut réussir...
Parce que, ça met du temps,
vous le savez bien,
pour le nouveau...
*-Je crois que ça a été dit
par d'autres intervenants,
mais la hausse prodigieuse
des prix de l'énergie
qu'on vient de connaître
a je crois permis de franchir
un certain nombre de caps
de sensibilisation et aujourd'hui,
je peux vous le dire,
je rencontre des artisans,
des chefs d'entreprise
et des ménages extrêmement sensibles
parce qu'ils ont vu la hausse
des prix de l'énergie,
euh, ces derniers mois,
et sont en train de rechercher
les investissements leur permettant
d'être plus efficaces et ils sont
en train de réfléchir à la sobriété.
Y a des concepts qu'il faut
qu'on arrive un peu à stabiliser.
L'efficacité, c'est quand
vous ne changez pas vos usages
mais avez simplement
une utilisation de l'énergie,
de plus en plus de l'électricité,
qui est moindre,
vous arrivez finalement
à améliorer le fonctionnement
du système énergétique.
Et puis, la sobriété,
c'est de se dire :
est-ce que, pour vivre seul,
j'ai besoin de 186 mètres carrés ?
Euh, c'est ça,
et du coup, effectivement,
un certain nombre de ménages,
d'acteurs économiques,
ménage ou entreprise, font ces choix
et je crois qu'il n'y a pas,
dans le contexte dans lequel on est,
y aurait pas vraiment
nécessité de rajouter
un signal prix fiscal
supplémentaire.
Il me semble que les prix
de l'énergie tels qu'ils sont
ont déjà convaincu tout le monde
de se mettre en mouvement.
-Madame Pompili,
je reviens vers vous
sur la taxation du carbone.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas vraiment
avoir un prix consolidé
du carbone pour réussir
ces avancées écologiques ?
-Si, évidemment.
Evidemment.
On a besoin d'un prix
pour le carbone
qui soit un juste prix,
c'est-à-dire qui représente...
-C'est quoi, le juste prix ?
La tonne,
ce serait...
-Oh, bah, plusieurs
projections ont été faites.
On était à 100 euros
la tonne comme objectif,
ça avait été une trajectoire
qui avait été prévue
par les précédents gouvernements,
ça a été stoppé net au moment
de l'affaire
des gilets jaunes,
mais tout le monde est assez
d'accord pour dire qu'on a besoin
de mettre en place une tarification,
une taxation du carbone
qui permette d'ailleurs de financer
aussi des politiques
de transition écologique.
Mais ça, ça doit aussi s'entendre,
j'insiste là-dessus,
mais ça doit aussi s'entendre
dans une relation
avec ce qu'on fait
avec les autres pays,
parce qu'on est
dans un monde ouvert,
dans un monde où il y a des échanges
commerciaux avec le monde entier
et donc, ça ne peut pas
s'entendre comme ça sans regarder
les conséquences que ça peut avoir,
sur nos entreprises
et sur nos consommateurs.
Quand l'Europe travaille
à un mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières,
porté très longtemps par la France
et enfin validé au niveau
de l'Union Européenne,
c'est un grand pas
vers une taxation mondiale
du carbone et en tout cas
vers une harmonisation
des règles aussi au niveau
international sur cela.
On ne pourra pas
y arriver si on ne met pas
en place ce genre de mécanisme.
Ca fait réagir,
on voit bien qu'il y a
des réticences,
que ce soit les Etats-Unis,
la Chine,
mais des expériences
se mettent en place
et je crois qu'on met en place
quelque chose de vertueux là-dessus.
-Louis Gallois,
nous sommes favorables
à des investissements
dans les biens communs,
qu'il s'agisse de l'eau,
l'énergie, la santé,
le logement, l'éducation
et autres services
publics,
notamment avec le modèle
sociale européen.
Sincèrement,
est-ce qu'il est possible
de faire tous ces investissements
sans croissance ?
-Ma réponse,
évidemment, c'est que non.
Mais je pense que...
Je... je participe...
J'ai pas participé
au débat précédent.
Moi, je pense qu'on dit...
Ici, y a une sorte d'unanimité
qui se présente,
autour de cette, de ce cercle.
Cette unanimité,
elle est pas dans le pays.
Bon, les problèmes...
Nous devons affronter
les problèmes.
Est-ce que, sur l'énergie,
par exemple, on est d'accord,
entre le nucléaire
et le renouvelable ?
Quoi sur le nucléaire,
quoi sur le renouvelable ?
Est-ce que...
Vous parliez
du prix de l'essence
comme un indicateur,
c'est très bien,
mais il va falloir
expliquer ça aux gens qui...
aux gilets jaunes.
Je pense que, notre émission,
il faut pas qu'elle soit regardée
par les gilets jaunes,
parce que nous allons
avoir des effets,
je pense, spectaculaires.
-Essayer de prévenir
les manifestations,
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire ?
-Je pense qu'on ne peut pas
établir un récit où on intègre
votre idée de financer
les biens communs...
-Ils sont indispensables.
-...sans faire des choix
qui soient clairs pour le pays.
Et je pense que ces choix
ne peuvent résulter
que d'un travail démocratique,
mené avec beaucoup de soin,
et ensuite une planification,
pour mettre en oeuvre.
Je suis désolé, vous parliez
tout à l'heure
de taxer le carbone.
Très bien.
-En quoi ça vous gêne ?
-Madame Pompili l'a rappelé,
Madame Pompili l'a rappelé :
on vit pas dans le monde...
On vit dans un monde ouvert.
Je rappelle la balance
commerciale de la France :
150 milliards de déficit.
Et ces 150 milliards de déficit,
c'est du carbone que nous importons.
Et qui, lui, ne bénéficie
d'aucune taxation.
Alors on va mettre en place
l'ajustement carbone,
je considère que c'est
un geste symbolique
important,
je ne veux pas le nier,
mais cet ajustement carbone...
-Vous êtes favorable
à cet ajustement ?
-Il faut voir dans le détail.
On va ajuster,
euh, on va taxer
l'acier brut entrant en Europe.
Très bien, ça va faire
que l'acier en Europe,
soit produit par les aciéries
européennes,
soit importé,
va valoir plus cher.
Bah, les constructeurs automobiles
vont construire
leurs voitures à l'extérieur
de l'Europe pour avoir
de l'acier moins cher.
Ils ont déjà commencé
à le faire largement,
ils vont poursuivre.
Faut-il taxer les automobiles ?
Si on taxe les automobiles,
je vous garantis
qu'on se retrouve à l'OMC,
Organisation Mondiale du Commerce.
Donc je pense qu'on a affaire
à des sujets extrêmement
complexes et qui supposent
des choix politiques
assez tranchés.
-Mais le fond de votre pensée,
Louis Gallois...
-Le fond de ma pensée,
c'est qu'il faut
jouer la croissance.
-Vous prônez
la réindustrialisation.
-Bien sûr.
-Vous pensez que
c'est possible en allant
vers une transition écologique
-Je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure :
les conditions
d'une réindustrialisation,
c'est d'abord, je l'ai dit,
un effort de recherche,
c'est ensuite que les process
industriels soient décarbonés,
et pour qu'ils soient décarbonés,
il va falloir que le pays
et l'Europe assurent
les conditions de financement
de cette décarbonation.
-D'accord,
vous parlez des citoyens,
mais les citoyens,
aujourd'hui,
vous parlez des gilets jaunes,
c'est une chose,
mais les citoyens aujourd'hui
contestent la notion
de PNB comme seul
indicateur économique.
-Non, non.
-Ils préfèrent aussi avoir
un indicateur qui soit plus social.
-C'est très bien qu'il y ait
des indicateurs sociaux,
j'ai présidé une fédération
de lutte contre la pauvreté,
j'ai quelques idées sur le sujet,
bon...
-Alors pourquoi...
Donnez-les-nous.
-Mais on a besoin
de croissance financière,
qui apporte de la ressource.
Vous parlez financement
de grandes infrastructures,
on a besoin d'argent pour cela.
Donc moi, je pense
que ceux qui plaident
pour la décroissance
plaident pour un modèle
social différent
de celui dans lequel nous vivons,
c'est-à-dire la fin
de l'Etat providence.
En revanche, si on veut
financer l'Etat providence,
financer les investissements
que vous évoquez,
il va falloir
de la croissance et,
cette croissance,
c'est un : de la recherche,
deux : des process décarbonés,
trois : de se positionner
sur les industries d'avenir,
des industries liées à la transition
énergétique et écologique,
et quatre : de produire
de l'électricité
en masse car on ne décarbonera pas
si on n'a pas beaucoup d'électricité
ou, si on veut décarboner
avec moins d'électricité,
on le fera en important
l'essentiel des produits.
Donc il nous faut de l'électricité
pour produire en Europe.
-Qu'est-ce que vous dites,
Barbara Pompili,
quand vous écoutez
un grand patron
comme Louis Gallois dire
qu'on a besoin
de croissance si on veut
financer les biens publics
qui sont requis
par la communauté nationale ?
-Je pense
que c'est une vision
que j'entends depuis toujours.
Je suis d'accord sur le fait
qu'il va falloir investir beaucoup
et que, pour ça, il faut de l'argent
et des moyens, maintenant,
on peut pas investir
en ayant en tête
de faire comme avant,
de faire business as usual.
-J'ai dit l'inverse.
J'ai dit l'inverse !
-Beaucoup plus d'électricité,
je partage,
et d'ailleurs,
toutes les analyses...
-Je suis désolé,
mais la programmation pluriannuelle
d'énergie qui est de votre époque
ne prévoyait pas
d'augmentation de l'électricité.
-Ca date d'avant 2015 et d'avant
l'accord de Paris,
ça date d'avant les objectifs...
de 2030.
-Ce qui nous a fait fermer
Fessenheim, quand même.
-Mais vous parliez tout à l'heure
de symboles, en voilà un,
de symbole.
C'est très gentil
de parler de symbole,
moi, je parle d'efficacité.
Nous avons aujourd'hui
des objectifs de baisse
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre
que nous n'avions pas au moment
où nous avons fait la LTECV,
nous avons des contraintes
qui ne sont plus les mêmes
qu'à l'époque et donc,
tout le monde a revu les objectifs.
On avait aussi d'ailleurs,
à l'époque de la PPE, planification
pluriannuelle de l'énergie,
pris des engagements...
-Ca date de 2020, je vous rappelle.
-...sur les renouvelables
que nous n'avons pas tenus.
A partir du moment
où ne nous tenons pas
des engagements
de plus de production d'électricité,
on va pas s'étonner qu'on ait
des problèmes de mettre en face
la production et la consommation.
Moi, je suis très
contente d'avoir été
une des actrices du discours
de Belfort du président
de la République.
Pourquoi ?
Alors que je ne suis pas
une défenseuse
acharnée du nucléaire.
Pourquoi ? Parce que, enfin,
on a tous, collectivement,
essayé de sortir
de nos propres dogmes
pour essayer de regarder
la situation en face.
Nous avons demandé des rapports
avec des projections,
c'est RTE qui l'a fait,
c'est l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie
qui l'a fait,
Megawatt avec ses propres,
avec ses propres analyses,
qui ont toutes dit la même chose,
qui ont dit :
nous allons avoir besoin,
pour baisser nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
de plus d'électricité,
tout le monde est d'accord.
Pour pouvoir faire face
à ces besoins,
les solutions sont
différentes selon les pays,
mais concernant la France,
on va avoir besoin
de trois choses, trois choses,
monsieur Gallois :
développer massivement
les énergies renouvelables,
beaucoup plus,
mais beaucoup plus que
ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui,
ce qui nécessite
beaucoup d'investissement,
on va devoir encore
se fonder sur du nucléaire,
et là,
je rajoute qu'il faut
quelques nouveaux réacteurs
car se fonder uniquement
sur les réacteurs anciens,
c'est un risque trop important,
et troisièmement,
troisièmement,
beaucoup de sobriété.
Et ce trépied-là
qui a été proposé
par le président Macron me semble
être le plus raisonnable et réaliste
dans la période actuelle.
Maintenant,
il faut qu'il y ait,
je vous rejoins là-dessus,
un débat démocratique
pour valider tout ça,
ce débat démocratique est en cours,
il y a en ce moment
des consultations des citoyens
sur le sujet du programme global,
il va y avoir
une consultation par la CNDP
sur les nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires,
il va y avoir,
et c'était une demande
très forte exprimée
quand j'étais députée avec d'autres,
une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle
de l'énergie précédée
d'un débat à l'Assemblée nationale,
donc c'est-à-dire
dans le lieu-clef
de la démocratie de notre pays
pour pouvoir donner
les grandes orientations,
en tenant compte
de nos objectifs climatiques.
-Vous voulez dire un mot,
et on demande le point de vue
de monsieur Ravignon là-dessus ?
-Je pense que...
la politique énergétique qui a été
menée par le pays depuis 20 ans
est une politique
totalement erratique.
-Beh justement, enfin !
-Mais j'ai approuvé
le discours de Belfort,
j'ai pas de problème
avec le discours de Belfort.
Je pense que nous avons besoin
d'énergie renouvelable,
je trouve absolument scandaleux
que l'Union Européenne
nous accuse de ne pas avoir atteint
nos objectifs en renouvelable
quand on voit l'énergie décarbonée,
l'électricité était décarbonée
en France comparée
à celle de l'Allemagne.
En France,
nous avons produit
de l'électricité
avec 107 grammes
par kilowattheure,
les Allemands sont à 700 grammes
et les Allemands se font
encenser par la Commission
car ils ont développé
le renouvelable
et nous nous faisons
accabler par la Commission.
-Vous montrez clairement
que les Allemands produisent
de l'énergie hypercarbonée
et que la Commission
européenne ne dit rien.
-Et d'ailleurs,
ce qui était paradoxal...
-C'est un chouïa caricatural.
-C'est une réalité,
madame Pompili.
-Ce qui est caricatural,
c'est qu'à midi,
la France était à 28 %
de renouvelable
et l'Allemagne à 29.
C'est-à-dire que,
comme il n'y avait pas de vent,
pas de soleil,
eh bien,
le renouvelable français,
c'était l'hydraulique
et le renouvelable allemand,
la biomasse.
-On va demander l'avis
de monsieur Ravignon là-dessus,
sur ce débat
autour de la croissance.
*-Je vais m'appuyer
là encore sur les travaux
qui sont des travaux
de prospective et des transitions
de l'ADEME sur 2050,
ce qu'on y voit, c'est que,
pour atteindre cet objectif
de neutralité carbone,
qui est vraiment fondamental,
sans quoi on n'arrivera pas
à stabiliser les choses sur le plan
du changement climatique,
eh bien on a un gros effort
de sobriété à faire,
ça a été bien expliqué,
on a un effort important aussi
de développement de la production
décarbonée d'électricité,
avec du renouvelable,
avec du nucléaire,
les proportions sont aujourd'hui
au coeur des discussions de la PPE.
Dans tous les cas,
il nous faudra développer
considérablement d'ici 2050
les énergies renouvelables car,
comme ça a été très bien dit,
même si on baisse
grâce à la sobriété un peu
notre consommation d'énergie,
on va devoir avoir une proportion
d'électricité plus importante.
J'ajouterai juste,
y a deux conditions supplémentaires
pour qu'on n'oppose pas,
mais c'était le thème
un peu provocateur de la réunion,
sobriété et croissance,
c'est qu'on soit,
et Olivier Lluansi l'évoquait,
sur un registre aussi
de souveraineté.
Je crois que ce sujet mérite
aujourd'hui d'être investigué,
que, dans toutes les démarches
que nous ferons,
dans tout le soutien
que nous apportons au développement
de telle énergie ou telle solution,
on ait toujours ce réflexe
de raisonner en filière.
On l'a insuffisamment fait,
l'éolien en est le plus bel exemple
et une grande partie
des difficultés d'acceptation locale
que nous rencontrons,
c'est lié au fait qu'il n'y a pas
de champions nationaux
dans cette, sur cette énergie-là,
et qu'on a bien du mal
à expliquer aux Français les emplois
qui se trouvent derrière.
-Vous l'avez dit, monsieur Ravignon,
on vous a entendu.
Vous vouliez rajouter
un point rapidement ?
-Un mot : la dernière condition,
c'est celle de la solidarité.
Les transitions que nous avons
à accomplir ne doivent
jamais oublier les plus modestes
de nos concitoyens,
sans quoi, effectivement,
eh bien, on va aller
vers de nouveaux épisodes
sociaux difficiles.
-Ce débat est intéressant,
mais pour conclure
et que les téléspectateurs
soient bien au courant,
est-ce que vous diriez
que la sobriété,
aujourd'hui,
c'est une opportunité
pour justement
cette croissance verte,
régulée,
sans atteinte écologique,
en préservant l'environnement
ou, finalement,
y a aussi une part, un peu,
d'hypocrisie et que c'est
un faux nez pour une décroissance
pour certains ?
Je commence par vous,
Olivier Lluansi.
-La sobriété ira
avec le développement
de notre outil productif,
sans doute avec de la croissance.
Est-ce quantifiable ou pas ?
Je pense que c'est bien trop tôt.
Et le deuxième élément
que ça apportera,
outre la souveraineté évoquée,
c'est qu'un outil productif,
ça s'installe dans les territoires,
auprès des villes moyennes,
ce qui permettra de baisser
l'intensité
de ce que j'appelle
le poison de la division,
nourri par notre économie
très tertiaire,
avec une concentration
de la richesse en métropoles,
et nous avons besoin
de cette cohésion
territoriale comme sociale
pour faire face à ces défis,
que ce soit celui de la souveraineté
ou de la transition,
qui coûtera beaucoup
d'investissement,
d'efforts économiques
et aussi l'effort de changer
nos habitudes.
Y aura pas que des solutions
technologiques
via l'industrie,
mais aussi des changements
de comportements.
-Hélène Peskine,
là-dessus ?
-Je suis gênée de ce débat
autour de la croissance,
qui est un terme aujourd'hui,
enfin, en tout cas, une quantité
qu'on mesure à partir
des consommations.
Aujourd'hui,
on ne sait pas décorréler
croissance et consommation,
or on peut imaginer
un développement alternatif
qui pourrait être prospère,
créer des emplois et des richesses
sans être systématiquement
corrélé à des consommations
qui, elles, peuvent être
néfastes pour l'environnement
mais aussi pour les inégalités
au sein de la société.
Je voudrais donner
un exemple très concret,
parce qu'on en a donné assez peu,
de sobriétés heureuses,
j'allais dire,
en tout cas sur lesquelles
on a trouvé des alternatives,
qui devront être financées,
la sobriété en sol,
la sobriété foncière
pour contrer l'étalement urbain
et notamment la disparition
de la biodiversité
ou des espaces agricoles
autour des villes.
Il existe des alternatives,
c'est la reconstruction de la ville
sur elle-même,
réinvestir des friches,
déjà occupées
par des fonctions urbaines
mais désaffectées,
éventuellement
augmenter la densité de l'habitat,
réutiliser
des logements vacants, etc.
On a des solutions qui existent déjà
et qui sont créatrices d'emplois,
qui sont créatives, même,
évidemment qui ont
un coût supplémentaire
mais qui ne génèrent pas
de difficultés à être réalisées.
Et je pense que
ça revient quand même
à la notion de récit,
mais on a besoin de représentations
de ces alternatives qui sont
quand même de la croissance,
ou du développement,
du développement urbain sur lui-même
mais aussi de la sobriété
car on n'étalera pas sur des espaces
naturels
des constructions nouvelles.
Là encore,
j'appelle à en avoir
une idée beaucoup plus concrète
de ce qu'est cette sobriété,
dans tous les enjeux
devant lesquels on est.
-Ecoutez,
c'est un débat
fort intéressant.
Je rappelle
une brève bibliographie.
Alors, le PUCA,
vous avez publié ceci,
dans le cadre un petit peu
de cette émission.
Hélène Peskine,
dites un mot là-dessus.
-Ca résonne avec ce que je disais,
c'est un recueil
sur les alternatives
à l'étalement urbain,
comment mieux marier l'agriculture
et la ville et transformer
la ville sans perdre
des opportunités de développement.
-Sur la décroissance,
y a de très nombreux ouvrages.
On en donne deux,
un ancien, un récent.
Voici un classique pour ceux
s'intéressant à ce sujet.
Et un plus actuel.
Ca vous intéresse,
Louis Gallois ?
-Je ne sais pas,
je ne l'ai pas lu.
-Alors je vous l'offre,
je vais vous l'offrir
non pas pour vous convertir...
-C'est très aimable.
-Je ne vais pas
vous convertir là-dessus !
Je voudrais signaler
aussi Olivier Lluansi,
vous avez publié
"Vers la renaissance industrielle".
Vous pouvez dire un mot
sur cette renaissance ?
On ne parle
que de désindustrialisation.
Cette renaissance industrielle,
vous la constatez ?
-D'abord,
y a quelques éléments
qu'on a indiqués,
oui, on a commencé à la constater,
oui, la crise de l'énergie
risque de casser un peu la dynamique
et on est dans une économie ouverte,
avec une concurrence
notamment de nos amis américains,
qui ont pris des modèles
sur le carbone
différents des nôtres.
La renaissance industrielle était
liée à plusieurs idées.
On n'a pas appelé ça révolution,
on affirme que,
pour cette réindustrialisation,
il faut les nouvelles
techniques
et nouveaux outils digitaux
et environnementaux
des nouvelles générations
et toute l'expérience acquise.
Produire quelque chose,
c'est 50 % de savoir,
50 % de savoir-faire,
c'est pas une révolution
mais une continuité
fondée sur les savoirs,
qui va transformer
notre outil productif,
pour un projet de société.
-Alors, je voudrais remercier
monsieur Boris Ravignon,
merci d'avoir été avec nous
depuis cette très belle ville
de Charleville-Mézières,
et cette place majestueuse,
vous voyez qu'on peut
aller dans le Grand Est
et voir du territoire
et du patrimoine.
Merci, madame Pompili,
d'avoir été avec nous.
Merci, Hélène Peskine,
merci, Louis Gallois
et merci Olivier Lluansi.
-Je précise juste que l'ouvrage
a été coécrit
avec Anaïs Voy-Gillis.
-Voilà,
donc merci à l'équipe de LCP
d'avoir permis la réalisation
de cette émission.
Je rappelle qu'on aura l'occasion
d'aller plus loin parce que c'est
une question centrale,
aujourd'hui,
sur laquelle
tout le monde s'interroge
en se demandant comment y arriver
et "qu'est-ce" qu'il est
possible de faire.
Et je crois que la narration
qui a été fournie,
ce récit national
que nous avons apporté,
modeste pierre à ce récit...
Et avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais
vous suggérer cette pensée :
"Il est impossible
de réduire sérieusement
"les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
"sans une discussion
sur la sobriété énergétique."
C'est de notre économiste,
prix Nobel,
Esther Duflo.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA